hello and welcome to this video for
round 12 of the candidates tournament
yeah the third that the right expression
third to last round yeah we are nearing
the end of the event and the surrounding
n brought changes in the lead of the
whole thing so we have some wins today
yeah let's see what happened i'm going
to start with spindly giri and this game
is awfully long really awfully long and
i'm going to keep my remarks light on
this we have from yeah more things to
look at in the other games and yeah
let's see what happened we have an
english opening and this time d 5 is
played surprisingly this is the first
time that this is plate in this
tournament we have seen a lot oops come
on a lot of this which is not the main
line but defy this and yeah surprisingly
this is the first time that is played it
has a very solid reputation here this
open that's an open sicilian reversed
and therefore surprising we see it only
now yeah it's a reversed dragon yeah the
miz g3 hear the difference are ever to
the dragon variation is that um in the
dragon quite often the white side
manages to cancel long and this is not
something that black can do here yeah he
cannot play like this should be six and
let's say castles and 3d seven yeah this
is going to be met by aggressive play
for white this extra tempo are not
having played d3 is really a huge
difference so Blackwell was an IP 6 and
plays in a more modest way with short
castles um before is the standard way
for white to proceed here playing on the
queenside
and black plays like that and putting
the knight on d4 after having provoked
before b5 the plane in this line mostly
um is going on on the queenside and in
the center now it's a tense middle game
with many pieces on the board um 92 I
guess somehow the software won't play it
out and please play that is there is 92
yeah I cannot resist temptation to point
out that you have to 92 there's a very
common blunder that keeps popping up in
games they move Knight to g5 it looks
completely a completely normal to
centralize the night but it has a huge
issue that white can actually take with
the bishop a weird-looking move giving
up the strong pc on g2 but after the
recapture and then III we see that black
has issues with this right yeah it's in
the middle of the board but attack now
and if you go to e6e for will trap this
Bishop amazing or night f5 oops is a
fork yeah or takes first and then
walking it's just as good yeah it's a
very common blunder there countess games
with this move and yeah Quincy 8 played
by giri is the best is a lobster love
ballet I just protect the b7 porn like
that III night at five and a former
Black yeah blankets try to keep this as
a good target night goes back to d6 and
white girls night de for he ultimately
tries to fight for this square and he
manages to get the night to c5 that's
usually an accomplishment however in
this particular position we see that
black with this trade and this trade
manages to activate the Queen again then
I'm upon here is currently poisoned
after 95 there will be 93 coming yeah I
mean what can delay this form for a bit
but yeah this is even worse yeah so it
cannot capture on c7 Bishop b2 was
played and i think around here we have a
position that is probably roughly equal
yeah why it has some play against this
pawn and black now we see you we line up
against the d3 pawn so it's probably a
position where those weaknesses somehow
cancel each other out give me place at
five whatever this is interesting now he
tries to get this f porn into the action
and I think I'm probably around here
sweedler plays a couple of um yeah
non-optimal moves the engine points out
that white should probably just keep
this tension here this tension and play
something like f3 or going to see to
yeah it's a it's not so easy to make
such a move keeping the tension is
difficult and chest and maybe he also
was worried about things here for
example black could decide to even bring
the H ponyo um still it's probably a
little bit better than the captcha after
this this now seems to be get weaker
than C 7s the night also comes to d5
black now pals up on the FL and after
rupee to now had an opportunity to get a
pretty nice advantage the move Knight
takes before was good now in this
position after Queen takes and which is
pretty clear I think that this is played
after the pawn capture him jack black is
happy
to grab the porn like that oops sorry
huh so takes and why should take with
the Queen yeah queen of three chick back
and now we have white can black and
insert this one and then grab this pawn
and here white will struggle floor the
draw here's a pawn down still reasonably
active so I'm not saying that this is
totally lost but black definitely has a
quite serious advantage here instead
giving played to move age six yeah he
was probably a freight office of his
background guess I'm rook to e8 and
indeed would be devastating as his
bishops controlling evade but this is a
bit um yeah it's not taking this
particular opportunity um again after 24
27 black is a little bit more
comfortable and in fact manages to get a
better ending um I won't analyze this in
big detail I mean it's it's possible to
look at most of those moves but they
traded down to this ending where black
was a pawn up and of course being a porn
up means you have some kind of winning
chances it is however there is no
particular situation where I had an idea
how black could play better or the
engine also doesn't point out something
it just keeps the position as it is and
I mean yeah obviously blackstone has the
pond but to win it's a different matter
why it's rooks are very active and the
sea porn which is the acid obviously is
still back on c7 it's not yet very
dangerous and receive channel check
after a couple of more movie that even
the h-bond here yeah the f porn John
gets traded and right now check
directors counter play against against
the g7 pawn yeah around here a little
bit later we come to the final I think
critical position of the game sweet let
some forcing that rope trade here and
now Gibby place came to age seven I
think after that is a draw like a clear
draw I think well after the best move
which is also pointed out by stockfish
black still can try successfully I doubt
it but you can try the king of eight is
the move that is a bit stronger I think
Rupert is seven to keep it on the
seventh and now the chick king f3 i
guess and roop 37 and this is probably a
stronger stronger try for an advantage
the White King is cut off and yeah black
can try to go over here with his King so
this is giving some chances I'm not
totally sure like I mean this is how it
will continue I am not totally confident
about how substantial blacks winning
chances are but at least he has some in
the game there is just nothing going on
and here this is this is very
interesting to try in the game of the
King edge seven and getting the King
here there is simply no winning try the
black king cannot go forward sg7 would
fall and you simply have no way to
improve the position the king of the
rook is staying on the 7th rank here the
white rook and yeah there's absolutely
nothing that black can do count blend a
plane control names are trying but yeah
King King to e3 check
this is not so clear in fact this is
probably bad right they have the King
kind of that's not a good idea the king
is cut off so this is this is stronger
this is stronger Black has no way
forward anyway other said King takes the
rook will capture and then this he
ponders easily stopped check yeah I porn
point why it just keeps the whole
situation and does not check all to read
it anyway check check check check can't
hear the draw was agreed it's kind of a
predictable result with geary involved
he has now played his 12th draw in a row
and again a game where he had some
winning opportunities um if he would
have just converted some of those he
would easily probably lead the event but
yeah it simply it somebody didn't didn't
work out and you can't can't blame him
for trying I mean he tried hard in this
game but couldn't get couldn't get the
win in ultimately um this means by the
way that swidler and geary they both
stay on fifty percent and their chances
of still winning the event are very very
low yeah i mean only with two wins now
in the remaining two rounds there is
some possibility and this is first of
all very difficult and even if they
would manage probably it wouldn't be
enough give you slightly slightly better
chance due to the tiebreak but it's it's
really it's very little um that is
possible still and okay next game to
check is kiwana a roni on one of the
co-leaders with fabiano caruana playing
Aronian was back on fifty percent after
you lost his dramatic game against Peter
Svidler and the road before
we have a somewhat predictable maybe
rule of pest but Aronian is not playing
the Berlin he he does have it in his
repertoire but he also plays this main
line and koala goals form for d3
directly showing that he does not want
to contest a marshal attack ok b5 and
castles yeah a couple of options here
black can also played d6 immediately and
move orders I'm very very critical in
this kind of opening but ok I don't want
to look look into this too deep we have
things to check later um yeah night to
a5 here the classical way of handling
the situation of the knight on c6 as
proposed by chigorin you have more than
120 years ago it's not the original
chigorin variation but this is what
sugar and always did attacking this
bishop and then plays c5 however aronia
doesn't play c5 yeah he could have done
so it's a perfectly reasonable move in
this position but this is one of his gas
special special ways of playing yes
played this this before instead of 95 by
the way black can also play entirely
differently with night to be 8 playing
in the briar style yeah also something
that is perfectly viable um ok night 85
and Bishop to e6 very interesting play
now by Caruana he goes before this is
something that he had played before this
kind of this kind of idea even against
Tyrone IAM and takes on a two-group
chicks and 96 the idea of before is
obviously to send the night back again
so that c5 now will become difficult to
achieve or even possible to achieve
Bishop g5 developing this quite a normal
move and now
have a novelty up to this point we were
following the game between vishy anand
and aronia in from the bow 2014 funny
enough in tournament that I was very
close to I was playing the European club
Cup event in the same playing hall so
this was probably play just a couple of
steps away from a table where I was
playing yeah back then Aronian was
playing Queen to d7 and after Bishop
takes Bishop takes 95 probably White had
a slight advantage yeah a little bit
more play on the queenside and um it's a
bit easier for white to come up with
active ideas him he now played however
the move Knight to d7 and yeah this is I
think a pretty pretty good idea trying
to trade off the bishop if white now is
totally unambitious he can take only
seven but after Knight takes this looks
very very solid for black yeah he was
gotten rid of that somewhat misplaced
night and there's really no particular
idea available for white now so Bishop
back that it also has a far more logical
move I why would you want to trade that
bad-looking Bishop only seven yeah and
all the idea comes just back yeah with
the intention of playing d5 and it is
difficult to prevent i mean i can't play
Bishop g5 but this is just a repetition
yeah and really not in the interest of
Kara wanna and still wants to fight with
the white pieces of course so Bishop g5
cannot be the way to go he tried to find
a way to um yeah adjust to that d5 move
being played and he came up with the
move Queen to be one not very intuitive
but quite interesting the ideas that
after d5 he played now Bishop to g5 yeah
this is the only way to react to d5 was
keeping some interesting play why
definitely does not want to take on d5 I
mean you can especially question this
with the Queen here but just in general
if we have this trade here Black is
really happy and the queen is strong on
d5 and black actually has a little bit
more space in this position so
absolutely nothing to fear white could
shoot for some c4 yeah he's not worse
but definitely not something that you
would play as white um if you are some
if you have some kind of ambition this
is far more the case with Bishop to g5
yeah now black has a couple of options
but Aronian goes for the most
interesting move and I think in this
game we really see that he still has not
given up any hope to win that event with
the win here he can get close to the
leaders again going back to a plus one
score and he goes he plays in a very
interesting way now let's deform um
black also could have just taken on you
for I don't think that this would have
been a terrible move and the big idea
that he has is that after Bishop takes
he's not playing the obvious move and
Bishop takes f6 yeah after Bishop takes
f6 there probably is 95 and here I mean
this is not very interesting for black
in comparison to what he tries in so he
avoided that and played d takes c3 very
surprising decision but a very
interesting decision and this is a kind
of a typical decision of Aronian yes
sometimes has those really
unconventional ideas that I guess are
very difficult to to fight against yeah
so what is why doing now okay you can
take on e7 you can take on d5 Bishop
takes you five wins upon and I think
should be played if you play this this
is really lame then black recaptures and
is ready to play 94 possibly provoking a
trade of those nights with the upon
coming to do
or and even yes cementing the strong
porn on c3 so this is nothing White has
to take the pawn bishop takes d5 and now
what exactly is blacks idea it's very
interesting he took this and played
queen to d6 attacking the e5 Knight it
doesn't have many squares g4 and f3 come
to mind nigeria's played in the game
Knight f3 also was possible I think the
play is kind of similar regardless of
white goes to g4 to f3 I mean okay no
it's different right the positions
differ but the what black is doing I
mean is kind of similar after Knight f3
he would play very live to the moon 85
attacking here those pawns on the
queenside and let's say it's not so easy
for white to play why it takes then
after Luke takes we see that this is
probably not going to be yeah going to
be held this pawn black also has a look
here and be for pretty strong initiative
so white won't take and the computer
suggest rook to a one back but then
after let's say c6 the position seems
very viable for black yeah let's say
it's difficult for wider to make
something real active here to play
something real active if you play a good
improving move let's say h3 something
that is kind of useful then black again
has a couple of options you can take and
now play a slow move or even think about
playing okay for it's also interesting
taking on differ on before actually
isn't that great as after those traits
the move 94 is a little bit awkward yeah
you have a hard time to defend those
this is also one main difference between
the night g4 idea and the move Knight f3
that 94-year can become an option for
white probably black will keep the
tension here and play a strengthening
move for example rookie a dork Sierra
flex it is a
down but this is very difficult to keep
in the long run anyway so interesting
and it's it's not a boring position
quite interesting yeah Nigeria wanna at
the end and blacks play is some kind of
kind of similar to what we have seen in
this line a five and six the difference
is that now that now White has has the
option to play a for you can also try
the move Knight f5 in this position
directly going for a trade yeah night f5
leg will play Queen two is six genright
will capture if it does not capture um
it's not quite clear what this has
accomplished so this is the position to
check yeah blacks idea is that whenever
white takes after Luke takes you will
have pressure against the pawn and black
is able to activate his pieces here
quite a bit here for example Queen to e5
possibly bring the Queen here yeah why
does a poner but it's not easy to play
at all I'm it i am not sure about this
position um the computer initially likes
white but I'm not sure that this is
really that brilliant yeah it's um it's
tricky to play I mean likes white means
like have a pawn or so and it's very
difficult to play I think can run I
wanted to play differently he played
this a for move and one idea of this is
that now the queenside get some yeah
gets opened up and you get this night on
that strong central square also note
that blacks pawn structure looks a bit
with direct to now yeah still those
poles are dangerous it's not like
they're there they're totally weak or
anything yeah this is now very
interesting yeah corona now decides to
take the bishop only seven and at first
I wasn't quite sure this is a this is a
great idea I was thinking if white stays
and tries to improve let
same um yeah what move some some some
small improvement move let's say that it
wasn't clear to me how black should
proceed but black has a good option in
playing rugae 3 yeah black gets very
active play with this for example if
white now takes I mean this is at least
a critical move i'm not sure if it's
actually the best movement this is a
credit critical move and snatching this
pawn we see that after be 495 black has
excellent compensation here fall upon
one point is that he can play this move
preserving this bishop that idea could
be that after g6 and Bishop g7 all of a
sudden this Bishop is covering this
promotion square what's definitely as
this is not a position that why should
aim for you if anybody black ass better
here so what did Kara wanna do yeah he
ultimately decided to take this bishop
it looks like this is not an easy
decision no because the night looks very
beautiful on d5 but we have seen that
there can be definitely um positions
coming up where the bishop can prove to
be quite strong so captured and now
queen bee three yeah aronia now after
queen bee three um plays a very
enterprising move he definitely wanted
to fight that or cosplayed age 52
sending in another yet another little
unit trying to disturb wide with h5 he
had easy options let's say up to to play
for example I think Luke III was very
clean a very clean and way to to end
this game in some in some way if you
want it takes takes if white is greedy
now is going to regret it yeah and yeah
white has no no good news anymore
thing like this it's just it just stop
playing for a loss here I am you cannot
do it like that this is too dangerous um
so what is the draw root k 1 is the
drone then B form and rook takes a three
with this kind of check this kind of
play why it will probably for the draw
it's not so apparent those poor girls
porn still look dangerous but there is
no way forward for black I think our
only unwanted to really as I said fight
at all costs and played h5 just keep the
tension yeah look to a one now traded
and Quincy five the point for black here
to try to play for win are those
advanced pawns there can be tactics like
b3 at some point and yeah also invasion
on the a file if possible so if anybody
black is playing for win here we come to
a critical position a couple of moves
later I think all this looks fairly
logical the White King here gets to the
center trying to help they both yeah
poke around a little bit let's say in
this position now Kara wanna it has a
couple of moves that keep the
equilibrium something like Renee to for
example he plays a move that looks
totally innocent okay one but in fact
after okay one now aronia had the
opportunity to win the game flat our to
win the game the thing is this is one of
those situations where um if the
computer points out like minus whatever
it is um people nowadays very often yeah
a quick in arguing ah why didn't you say
where didn't you see that hey it's as
easy win and the thing is this is not an
easy wind it isn't easy at all let's
have a look rook takes the three is of
course if this is what he played by drug
takes c3 yeah okay um yeah white should
take it right then
thing else doesn't make any sense so it
takes checks um okay king is in check
the first thing to check here what
happens after King to g1 this is in fact
easy and for a player of ronnians level
or any decent level pretty easy that
Quincy four wins the game now yep if
white trades then those pawns promote on
their own yeah this is pretty pretty
clear right yeah one point is that after
this this still be three and sear the
pawns promote and said this is this easy
to see white also um yeah I mean you can
try to avoid the trade here but after c2
we see that black will promote here
Quincy one Queen deform and B 3 and so
on that this is easy that is definitely
aronian easy saw that they're very
clearly he looked at the move quite
quite clearly and but the problem is a
different one this is the problem white
can go to yvonne and this is far more
difficult black can actually pretty easy
it's also easier you can see that black
can just take this pawn and continue
from here and okay you have to draw in
hand this is cool but yeah aronia
definitely wanted to win this yeah and
it's it's one thing you can play this of
course and now see if you can find a win
but it might as well be that you don't
have any and then you question this
decision why did I take or do you three
in the first place if I force a draw
thing is it is not a draw it is a win
but to see that beforehand very
difficult the wind starts with Queen DJ
check king of one and now see two okay
so far so easy and it's a clear threat
yeah the only thing that yeah that makes
your question this whole thing is of
course queen bee to check very important
and black has to react probably with f6
yeah f6 and this is the moment where you
probably yeah stop your calculation
and kind of ask yourself okay is that
really enough how am I going to do that
are those pawns really worth more than
the white rook the the amazing thing is
that white here has absolutely nothing
that you can do against black playing b3
b4 and Queen to see three this is really
amazing if white stays let's say and
doesn't do anything like rook see one or
so okay then Tancredi one is made and
it's a stupid move but let's say rook e1
ya b3 and now just go back again quit
you want to keep blundering here and
yeah why didn't write is in white is
losing it what can you do I can check
your area and then go back I just wanted
to show the winning idea before it's
really cool yeah that now there is no
way to prevent Quincy three it's really
really nice the relatively best thing
that white can try in these kind of
situations is to to get into this and
lang but this also will be lost with the
beep on it's really remarkable if we go
back again I mean I made some very
stupid looking moose and here white has
no way to save himself it's really
remarkable he can can check here King
age six and now recognize that there's
no way of stopping tweenty one made and
see one it's it's it's really it's lost
it's a losing position but yeah it's not
easy to see we can try this by the way
can you want to get out of the mates but
again p 3 rook c1 and before and you
cannot stop this yeah it's really cool
and the bonds will decide it's very nice
so route cactus t3 was winning but it
wasn't obvious at all again it's easy to
criticize but it's especially when you
want to win if you are in a situation
where you don't really have to win it
all costs and Aronian had to to keep in
tournament and you in those situation
you might as well take then say okay
have the draw in hand and let's see
maybe I find some win and then you
probably will find it right but it's
move 38 you want to win and you can also
just keep the position end and kind of
grind on and this is what he ultimately
did a Quincy five green j7 thing is it's
still kind of interesting in this
position because black has options here
to move his paws an option that white
does not really have the position is
still more comfortable for black to play
and we will see that a little bit later
aronian will get a second chance here in
this position kawana and is still under
pressure there is there are those ideas
here the invasion ideas and he decides
to play the move route 288 and it seems
that after Luke a8 he again gets into
trouble it seems that queen bee one for
example was a bit better yeah Queen to
f4 this is now getting difficult the new
g4 is really disturbing but yeah similar
to the rook takes 2-3 situation it is
not that easy after Luke a one aronian
kg4 and after this this capture decided
to just recapture with the Queen which
is the most known move ever but it seems
that the move roop to d6 was indeed
quite strong the idea being to swing the
rook over and attack with rook and queen
in a situation where the white queen is
somewhat offside yeah one line that is
given by the engine he ever stop fish is
Queen takes rook to f6 queen to deform
tears and then be four
and it's very difficult still for why
two defenders yeah Queen takes before
loses directly due to age two check
check yep that is going to be made even
and it's difficult for white to suggest
a move for white him the engine wants to
play a three but after Queen f4 again
blacks pressure is probably yeah it's
probably decisive it was a second
opportunity probably for Ronia to UM to
win this game with room 26 he took on g4
with the chick and still after hoopty
six yet the same idea he's still having
enormous pressure but im mean neither me
nor the engine seized a clear win
anymore yeah if the engine doesn't see
anything here then it's probably just
that there is nothing even though there
are still probably some opportunities i
mean it's it's just very very
complicated um Luke f6 Quincy three
Queens you two still looks critical but
maybe why it just is just about just
about saving this x3 Queen IAM check
yeah it is it looks very dangerous here
at the pawn but Jack White has resources
like this check check now he tried h 2 &
goo cage one is just about chat here
getting into this rook ending this still
jan looks it looks a bit critical for
white but i think now it is really a
draw with precise play yeah there are
there are still some options i know but
if i analyze every move here this this
thing is going to be two hours long yeah
here they agree to a draw that's
probably no way no way forward if black
decides to grab one of the parts then
the deep aunt is going to be the decider
him I mean decided in terms of a draw
check it's one way to get this to her to
a complete draw yeah very tough fighting
game and a very good game i think by am
yeah by both players actually aronian
was pressing very hard with inventive
play but karana didn't didn't break down
he could have lost probably at two
points but this is just what happens
it's a it's a tough tough tournament ya
know on round 12 and yeah spoiled
opportunities for iranian who where the
wind could have gotten yeah could have
gotten back into them into the event I
mean it still would have been difficult
but at least it would have been a very
serious chance okay so let's have a look
at the next game which is kayaking to
par love you should find my notes though
otherwise not going to tell you more
than some general ideas okay so h3 is
played here against the night off by the
way this is the first the first Sicilian
we see in this event yeah every game
that started with 14 was 15 and was
either Spanish a window pass on Italian
game and this is the first Sicilian
tapado of course is a lifelong night off
player in particular so this is not them
a particular surprise I still think it's
surprising that in the event we have
seen only e4 e5 because there are
players in the event who play the
Sicilian or some other openings here and
there ok if I've has the most reliable
reputation of the on the highest level
but but still okay so we have
now against this h3 line and black has a
couple of options and the very topical
recently was a five and then h5 or
b-five both very interesting ways of
playing but the pile of go see six which
is maybe the sharpest move as it allows
this G for expansion night ft seven
there should be three and we should be
seven and g5 yeah white is expanding on
the kingside the part of us really out
for a big fight him um a black cannot
take this by the way because 96 is
somewhat embarrassing reply am giving
white check a huge advantage in this
position so just be five III difficult
for why to do without this move and no
h4 so white has gained lots of ground on
the on the King side it's quite funny
that we basically see now a carries
attack against the flavor ningun but
with a's h3 and h4 why does the tempo
down on this on this line but still
probably in rather good shape this whole
position looks dangerous for black and
taupe olive in fact has experience with
this position after castles 22 yet
played the move knight c6 in a game
against paco vallejo in 2012 also
looking completely normal normally he
does something different in this game he
plays Knight to be six the idea of night
be success to get both nights in
connection here with this with the c-4
square so that night can come there and
and stay there he wants to really get
this ambitious plan going the drawback
of this is it it costs quite a bit of
time quite quite
kidding still it probably is not bad
it's just rather risky yeah h5 not by ki
can just getting the bonds going um 987
and g6 white is not even bothering to
Castle long you just place this standard
attacking moves them as quickly as
possible trying to bust open black some
kingside the next move now is probably
it's risky but probably still okay it's
actually very difficult to tell in such
a position if you just invest the time
that I could invest now to analyze I
assume that this is still okay it is a
risky move but it's probably okay night
c5 was also possible to put more
pressure on that you for porn okay long
castles age six also was moved but okay
no castles night bc form takes takes it
was the idea he wanted to keep this
night on c4 now after Queenie to we get
to the critical position of the game and
it is actually the only critical
position of the game as now topalov
played the move um look to c 8 and
frankly speaking i don't understand what
his idea was because after rook c8 um
why place the the totally obvious move
that was the idea all the time and then
black is just losing i mean and very
obviously you're losing so it's very
it's very unclear what two part of
overlooked or what his idea was um
instead of rook c8 he had some still
options to to play him a decent position
for example with bishop f6 this is
something that still works the idea is
mostly to get this yanira the king so
that h6 now can be answered with this
caption and after this you have this as
a defensive piece so we can take on g7
why it still has an attack that's it's
absolutely out of the question but it's
not an attack that will just win after
Lucas e8 why place the standard move age
six this is totally clear that this is
coming and after that you can basically
resign I mean it's just over white
threatens to take on g7 or take on h7 I
mean both both as is winning and you
simply have no defense I mean what you
places he t 2 takes there and gives the
exchange and is lost so it's really a
bit mysterious what is what his plan was
we have to see that something like this
for example is not simply not working as
Y shakes yeah King here chattox tragic
and now here and the idea is root g8 and
queen age six you know there's simply no
defense IAM then what moves you can take
this but h takes g7 and now okay after
King takes this is that simple end and
enough to win like this this threatening
night here or alternatively rookie aight
then queen f3h three wins it's the
mysterious thing is that age six is kind
of what else is that what else move and
if you have no reply to that why do you
play rook c8 so it's it's a bit strange
kayaking probably was also pretty
stunned that he just ignored white some
whites basic idea h6 yeah okay six he
had to play this in order to avoid the
chick mates but after 96 white is
completely winning so night f8 do ship
f8 and Tim kayaking definitely now
doesn't want to spoil this so just place
red
it's simple and simple way there were a
couple of options that the the engines
point out that one quicker or so but
this is not the point you want to be
saved him and he keeps us some exchange
up activates his pieces yeah the Queen
gets up to age six driving the black
queen away and now again g3 is a good
move now I text this night and okay
black of course can never take because
h7 is hanging so my tix here we go just
recovering the night just to be sure and
be ready to use the rookie on the
third-ranked again threatening on age
seven now the night is coming in to
deliver them yeah the final blouson j
and after 23 here to power of resigned
the thing is that we are threatening why
the threatening rook g6 and for example
let's say night here then which is six
is the end of game check nice one mate
or here 9006 which wins everything so a
very strange game i think because on
that level I mean age six is the totally
clear threat here and I don't I don't
see how you can play rook c8 I mean it
just bits basically gifts why at the
point very important win of course for
kayak and he had a loss in the round
before against the ship but now is back
in the hunt with plus two so he is cool
leading the event again with plus to the
hi-low game to look at is the game like
a moi Anand and still through screwed up
the sorting of my notes so let's go to
LA camera Hamid so here we again have
a/c 45 and was she playing Bishop before
line that we have seen a number of times
already in the event 95 this has been
tried before in an earlier round by
Topalov against aronia we had this
before 9h four and after castles I think
um what's the T action I think after
here I should have looked that up I
think the pile of went for night eggs
before here against aronia and then play
Bishop g2 and d3m well now can we
replace differently plays Bishop g2 and
yeah attacking this pawn indirectly
taking here taking only for Maddie sixes
play this is probably the sharpest move
that's also a rookie idea which is the
other way to protect the e4 pawn um ok
d6 and white now play the move a 3
pushing the bishop back and castles yeah
so in this position is the first where
you have to take a serious look um
Duluth look to am sorry the move g5 we
have to look at this first the move g5
in this position um isn't actually a
mistake it looks like a strong move
because in a Texas a night that doesn't
have a square but White has a very
strong reply in deform this is a very
good move and a very common motif in
this line where the night on h4 is on
the edge of the board the big problem is
that Bishop takes you five is such an
such a brutal pin that black cannot do
this am I mean white can even take on c5
but Bishop g5 looks interesting I can
actually take on d4 here right this is a
little bit different than user in those
positions yeah I'm sorry white is
probably taking this as a stronger
the threat since Bishop g5 so that black
doesn't have time let's say to take em
and then this would happen yeah this
looks wrong in taking here probably is
best and black skin side is totally
wrecked yet with g5 being played yeah
and I played so look to e8 and
centralized this rook and in this
position nakamura played a new move it's
it's technically a novelty plate the
move III yeah what is the point of this
move yeah one important thing is that it
covers the d4 square so if white would
have played before instead then Bishop
to d4 is a move attacking this rook with
the tempo so he is avoiding this
possibility with e3 the big thing is of
course after e3 there is still the issue
of this stranded night on H form and in
fact here and unplayed the move g5 and I
was really surprised that that that he
went for it um it's it's just such a
such a sharp decision maybe maybe I'll
not also was thinking that he yeah
should get into some kind of
complications I really try to win
another game and this is really possible
um but yeah let's look at the
alternatives I think that ultimately g5
is probably a bit too risky but ok we'll
see how it unfolded um what else is
there it's not that easy actually
because if white gets to ya play moves
like before Bishop be tool and I think
you about the better position the knight
on d5 is strong and in many cases white
can also play move like f3 to get rid of
that you for corn and simultaneously
open up the bishops
diagonal and also the f file so if we
play I mean I know that I know it's
really ridiculous but something
something really stupid move like
nothing here some nothing move then
reform and Bishop b2 will just be
excellent for what yeah he's threatening
to take here to damage the pawn
structure and black is running out of
moves he already okay six is very
ridiculous but yep a much stronger
movement comparison is especially six
maybe looking at look at this let's not
look at a nonsense move yeah here for
example also why could go on before push
it back and now a couple of interesting
options even f3 as an interesting move
here yeah trying to open up the position
yeah like night x and c takes Bishop
takes Bishop b2 yeah this is quite
dangerous here interesting player there
are also alternatives of course but can
just play Queen to be three for example
to support d5 and go Bishop between next
I would like YTM to be honest but it's
not probably as clear as it's not a
clear advantage or anything like that
even in this position by the way still
g5 is possible and after this 97 y can
try various ways to sacrifice this piece
now he can also play this and tons of
possibilities I played g5 and said I
think it's probably quite a risky so
before is the idea clearly attacking
this bishop and unplayed Bishop to b6
and I think after that he's probably in
real trouble then the engine gives this
right you have to say that I don't fully
trust this either but it's definitely
better than what happened in the game
very deaf I mean all take all this has
to be taken with a grain of salt because
you
have to probably look a little bit
deeper to be totally sure okay after the
capture what is what doing you will play
Bishop b2 it's ultimately a double
attack and that Bishop is still hanging
but the night is also hanging and this
only this possible cakes Teague's and
yeah what is black doing now the engine
suggests 95b takes and Bishop g4 indeed
interesting yeah Queen to be three I
guess yeah the move f3 is it's looking
interesting but probably ultimately not
so great because black is not taking
this exchange but developing the screen
to set up a real yeah a real pen yeah
taking is less convincing even though
yeah this is also not fantastic for a
while so oops that was a bit much I'm
sorry for that so what was the end of
the dash at this one takes here
yeah take take 95 takes Bishop before
headed was the suggestion queen bee
three and then nine and three check this
is given us equal buy a stock fish after
you let it calculate a bit but after
takes takes age three I think I still
prefer white was got this King edge to
look g one option very difficult
position that bishop on me too is
monstrous okay the f3 bishop also looks
dangerous but wide still has some porns
left to cover so i think i still rather
be white here even though if the engine
gives 000 in this kind of position it
has some it has some meaning yeah and
probably this is what island had to do
after Bishop b6 but should be too i
think he's in real trouble he has to
take now on d5 there is no no big
alternative and now why we kept just
note that like it's not even getting to
the point where he can take the night he
just isn't doesn't have the time in a
way yeah if he takes the night now on h4
then white will just capture and play
Bishop sorry if you play Queen to h5 and
we already see that this cannot be yeah
this cannot be good for black put it
let's put it like that and other options
I'm 95 maybe the most obvious talking
move after that f4 is strong yeah F 494
probably and white can simply take on g5
very very dangerous position yeah the
relatively best is Queen takes g5 and
then Bishop f6 and I don't think that
black is going to be able to withstand
that attack yeah he played knife deform
not not happy I'm not happy about this
but at least that closes the diagonal
note that
wyd now shouldn't just take this night
yeah if he takes like this like here
here here this position is still kind of
playable for black what nakamura played
is a lot stronger he played the move d3
simply ignoring the night on h4 like he
did the whole game basically yeah and
now black is um yeah running out of
options in a way he has to take the
night now so I took it and now just D
takes you for very nice he just a Texas
now for for real let's say intending
Bishop takes Bishop takes Queen takes
like this this this and well night has
to move them but where to go F went to
e6 okay I mean you can go to be five but
after a four he was still don't have a
square so a pretty awful situation yeah
96 was played d takes and rook takes and
now be five and yeah this is move 17 and
yeah black is busted it's just what it
is both wide White's bishops are
fantastically strong and why doesn't
even had to sacrifice material for this
great position well black is lacking the
Jeep on real badly yeah he took plate 22
g five but now it's easy for what to
play takes rook takes Queen to be three
intending to set up that battery on the
long diagonal ja allen tried h5 now
which doesn't help but I think it was
probably already quite desperate yes
lost two games already on the black side
of flank openings he lost against
kayaking against Knight f3 III and see
for and against 1c4 against kawana in
the same line with for Bishop before
yeah I don't know it with hindsight if
it was a great idea to repeat that that
Bishop before line there's d phi there's
94 there are some options to deviate
okay it's a hindsight's 2020 we know the
thing yeah okay h5 it doesn't help but
it was already pretty pretty bad luke t
1 is strong try to trade this only
active look that black ass it was
avoided and rook 25 and now the camera
found the decisive maneuver he's also
better with other moves but what he
plays a strongest currency for the idea
is to swing over here get the Queen
directly near the King Bishop g4 if
Bishop to e6 then Queen f4 is winning
the rook is just hanging and like this
this this is already an unavoidable mate
yeah so this was played between a for
tempo on the rook rook went to g6 Ruby 5
now we should be form and uh not reside
there's simply no way out here you can
look at this end but after Luke g5 this
is a winning attack jay king of a dent
now yeah everything once you can just
take here also why this material up and
has this decisive attack yeah so a
pretty bad loss for foreign idea who's
back on a plus one school just after he
had won this game against Iraq in the
round before he's now back on +1 the
tournament situation is still very very
tense but we can be pretty sure that one
of the three players currently leading
will actually pull through kiwanuka
yakeen are leading with plus two and are
not on plus one koala and ki can
actually still have to play each other
in the final round which will be of
course super crucial if this game as the
winner the winner of that game will vary
to win the event I actually thought
about pulling up the cross table at the
end of this video and discuss a couple
of options but it's actually rather
complicated I mean okay we can have a
quick look at the cross table but it's
difficult to look through all possible
scenarios in the last two round just
give me a second to pull it up yeah here
we have the cross table yeah I'm taking
this from chest 24 as you can see so
greetings of someone from chest 24s
watching this video and so just have
just a quick look we have kayaking
kawana leading the event and online
training we have three guys on fifty
percent for those fifty percent guys the
only chance would be two wins and even
then hmm it's not necessarily enough so
very likely kayaking or Caruana would do
it they have this game left in the final
round we see only one draw here and
kayaking would still play Aronian or
kawana has to play swidler um for
Sevilla the next round he also still has
a slight chance if he managed to win
against karana it's not totally I mean
this would would equal the score against
him and put them on the same points it's
not totally off this idea thats villa
could beat him and get into the action
it is possible that one of the fifty
percent cars can all the Sun get into
contention and still play some villa and
geary so Giri is notoriously difficult
to beat of course and speed llam are not
displaying with black hmm also not easy
and so tap too tall order so for Vichy
it's difficult definitely so koala kayak
in the final round will be would be very
very crucial but I think to go through
all of the possible scenarios especially
regarding this tie break rules it
doesn't make sense to do this now
because there are so many
possible options so we will have to look
at round 13 which is going to be played
on on sunday saturday the 26th of the
resting and after that we can see the
different scenarios the crucial thing
will very likely be if this game
kayaking kawana if someone just needs to
draw there or not it's probably clear
that the winner will qualify very likely
at least but the interesting point can
be with various tiebreakers ever draw is
is enough one of the players for example
I don't want to go into this any further
if we would have four drawers in round
13 so all drawers and then we have
karacan can wanna play against each
other in the final round there can be a
very weird situation that with the draw
it looks like kayaking qualifies because
he has more wins they have two draws
against each other in this case but it
can happen that if V she catches on that
all of a sudden and yeah he qualifies
because he has more wins among them no I
think that Kara wanna actually would
qualify it's varied it's very confusing
so let's not get into this I try to work
this out but probably failed so we look
at them round round for 13 and then
we'll check what kind of options they
are for the hip for the final round it's
definitely a tense intense competition
with at least yeah three players still
in it if one of the fifty percent guys
wins and move 13 hmm may still be
interesting okay I hope you enjoyed the
comradeship thanks for watching